Hilary Clinton is in some hot water with
President Obama she's been making the
rounds you know she's in the media every
freaking day and she basically said that
Obama should have armed the Syrian
rebels which we've already been talking
about and why do we think that would
have worked I do not know but The Daily
Beast had an interesting piece on this
according to one of the lawmakers
senator bob Corker asked the president a
long question that included sharp
criticism of President Obama's handling
of a number of foreign policy issues
including Syria Isis Russia and Ukraine
Obama answered corker at length then the
president defended his administration's
actions on Syria saying that the notion
that many have put forth regarding
arming the rebels in Syria would have
led to better outcomes in Syria was
horseshit holy cow the president kitty
said horseshit so this seems like it's a
kind of direct attack on Hillary why is
it a direct attack on Hillary because
she because does she give McGurk but her
quote about arming the rebels was pretty
tepid like this is a first of all this
is gonna be nothing in regard to Hillary
and Obama yeah it is not in Hillary's
interest to be seen as an Obama Lackey
at all she has to stay close enough to
him so she doesn't alienate mainstream
Democrats she'll won't do that but
obviously showing some independence from
the administration that is relatively
unpopular not as unpopular as people
would like to have you believe is a
useful political tool but she didn't say
anything like Obama made a mistake she
said that she argued knowing how
difficult to arm a certain select group
of Syrian moderates and that it might
have helped and now the reason this is a
story is because the president said the
word portion which is horseshit like he
may have said it I hope he said it
that's a human moment that he had the
White House has confirmed the exchange
was senator corker of Tennessee they
have not confirmed the use of the
expletive [ __ ] you who cares whether he
used that horseshit in a private meeting
oh great now Ben mankiewicz said [ __ ]
you about horseshit but we've got the
quote from Hillary Obama's failure to
help build up a credible fighting force
of the people who were originators of
the protests against Assad there were
Islamists there were secularists there
were everything in the middle the
failure to do that left
vacuum which the jihadists have now
filled so I had read well you're
retracting your exactly that's a straw I
still don't think it's anything and I
still think the political part of this
stands that's a strong that's that's a
strong anti Obama quote but that said
it's there are plenty of Democrats in
the House and the Senate who believe
that exact same thing who were at that
big lunch of lawmakers with the
president to discuss foreign policy
right before Congress went on recess
Hillary now is encounter among them
there is obviously a significant
disagreement about what we should have
done in Syria I don't think it's that
big a deal that it suggests that there's
a huge fight yeah all right well you hit
most of the meat here but is part of
this just that Obama is basically in
lame duck territory at this point so
Hillary by hitting him no no see her
back right I agree there's no sweat off
her back I think Tuesday I just want to
make two points you know Hillary saying
that's completely politics and she's a
war hawk and she's a corporatist and
she's our liberal I can't what do you
make of her moving to the right now
because she lost into this because she
went to the right well but that's what
she did in 2002 the right right Obama so
lost so why do it now doesn't this seem
a little early actually you know it's
just just the way the gears work man
she's been doing she's been to the right
ever since 1992 so what she doesn't know
how to do anything else
I mean she's sitting on the boards of
Walmart she's deregulating [ __ ] she's
pushing forward a corporatist health
care reform she's she's deep regulating
Wall Street she is exactly the opposite
of FDR see the exotic she might be good
on women's issues and that's what we're
left with we're left and the margins
lilly Ledbetter and abortion but not the
core thing that makes people radical
that makes clive Bundy and all those
[ __ ] want to take up arms against
the government it's because we're being
screwed over the biggest ass reaming in
the history of this country is happening
right now from the military-industrial
complex
and Wall Street and they somehow got us
[ __ ] angry at each other because
there's no good jobs fifty percent of
the people in America earn less than
thirty thousand dollars that's workers
so there's a big problem that creates
unrest and that's what's gonna
radicalize America and she's part of it
and the reason she goes Oh the problem
here is brocco
and he didn't arm the freaking rebel the
problem is there was a goddamn drought
in Syria that's what this all got
started because there was a drought and
people didn't have jobs their farms
failed they went into the cities there
was no food and water in the cities and
the unite and the world did not respond
people at they asked for help in Syria
and they did not respond sorry to
filibuster but I think that what's
interesting about what Jimmy said I
agree with I think a hundred percent of
it we just agree with yourself a second
ago give me a second yeah come around uh
if Hillary had shown backbone that she
is once again not showing in 2004-2005
and come out against the Iraq war any
time before it was like the meter went
yes okay now it's safe to come out
against it she'd be President United
States yes so no doubt lesson lesson not
learned no and if Barack Obama would say
horseshit more often he would be a more
effective president they have a real
moment instead of always constantly
choosing his words with a million odds
and qualifiers in between that's why
people like George Bush because he said
stuff like horseshit and he did any talk
like a regular person so people thought
it was authentic and people think Barack
Obama isn't authentic because he's not
authentic alright so real quick is the
horseshit moment is that just sort of
like Obama's just I feel like he's just
kind of done now like he's ready to move
to Palm Springs I just man if he would
have been done six years ago he could
have got a lot more [ __ ] done that's the
truth